blade Smiths it's that time of the year
when the chill in the air turns into a
chill that runs down your spine it's our
Halloween themed competition gentlemen
how many of you guys have a knife
graveyard all right we have a similar
tradition here in the Forge all those
blades that don't make the cut we've
repurposed into our very own Iron Maiden
check it
out
blad smiths in the first round you will
need to harvest at least three of these
dead blades and Forge a Billet from
which you will make a zombie apocalypse
knife that is between 14 and 16 in in
length as measured from tip to plunge
grind this blade must also have three
gut hooks along the spine you'll have
just 3 hours to forge your blades here
in the first round failure to meet a
single one of our parameters
well you can see what happens of those
guys good luck blade Smiths your 3-hour
starts
now these are all Blades of Broken
Dreams there are built-in problems in
these blades that these Smiths are going
to have to identify and work around I'm
not going to discriminate too much as to
what blades I'm choosing I want three
blades that have a lot of meat on them
it can't get any scarier not knowing the
Steel type I decided to do a spark test
when you do a spark test you want to
look for bright short Sparks looks like
fireworks it all spark tested well I
think my chances are pretty good I'm
using a sand my technique I basically
took two pieces from two different
blades and sandwiched onto another blade
PR get a good Forge weld out of it I cut
a handful of blades off just so I can
have a variety to pick from I'm looking
for something that is a solid steel that
don't have scale and they look like they
are one piece of Steel go a canister
Damascus it's the safest way because we
don't know what kind of Steel is in
there I figure I'll have the best chance
with canister with a powder high carbon
steel I know for a fact I'll have a hard
Edge on my
blade right now I've got three blades
what I think is the hardest and it's
also the thickest blade that's in the
center and I've got two billets on
either side and I'm just going to
sandwich them all
together I'm anticipating I'm going to
run into a problem somewhere with these
so the quicker I can get those Forge
welds starting the sooner I can address
those problems as they come up Trevor
cooked his white out before he put his
candy together so you notice that can's
not peeling off real
easy I get the general shape of my blade
I got the tip in I got the curvature so
what I'm making is a big recurve knife
meant for slicing and chopping what do
we expect out of a zombie killer I like
something with wide blade on it then you
can just CHP away yeah you know things
about zombies these are slow chop the
arm chop the leg and come back for the
head later on Alex does have a pretty
nasty looking zombie killing blade out
there I use a angle grinder and I get
the initial hooks cut in how did you
relieve some of that stress clean it up
clean it up make it smoother get it
almost polish okay and then use a Dremel
to round the edges off Square notches
and a blade it's just asking for more
trouble the cane is sticking on all four
sides at the bottom and it's just
looking horrible right now I'm getting
really scared that I made not be able to
finish come on Trevor in my mind I'm
thinking if I cut this loose hanging bit
off I can grind the rest off so I start
grinding I just got to grind as deep as
I can without ruining the Billet and I
finally get everything sorted out and I
still have a huge Billet I got to get
back in the Forge
now the plan is just to make a long
chopper with a thick spot it should chop
through a zombie
fine is that a
quench I come out of the oil I realize I
got a slight warp on just my Tang I
decide you know straighten it out as
best as I can on the Anvil and then hit
the grinder grind out what I need to
when Jay neilson's beaten into a
tombstone if it's going to break
somewhere it's going to break on one of
those gut hooks so I put them right
towards the tip where there's plenty a
mass below them that hopefully the shock
won't just go straight to them but
rather it will disperse throughout the
blade evenly personally I do not like
gut hooks but I will say my gut hooks
look
vicious BL F 15 minutes 15 minutes
remaining I pull it in and out of the
forge trying to make sure everything's
even nice salmon color is what you want
there there you go at least he didn't
pun it when it was too hot I pull it out
of the oil it's got a bad warp in it
let's lay it on the Anvil real quick see
if it's stra sign to warp hey a little
warp right there 15 seconds will starts
counting down and I get worried I'm flip
it over so the scoop side is facing up
and I'm hoping that it'll suck the heat
out of the middle and bring that warp
down
slowly 5 4 3 two one BL Smith shut down
your machines drop your tools pull your
blade out of that acid Edge this first
round of competition is
over blade Smiths welcome to the
strength test using the most violent
action we could come up with we will
test your Blade's Edge and strength of
construction by Smashing it bashing it
and violently slashing it into this
headstone and who's going to do all that
for us our own beast from the East Jay
neelen Alex you're up first are you
ready yeah all right
[Music]
J you sure that's J
Jay's wearing a hockey mask an apron and
he's carrying a big old machete that's
covered in
blood I feel like I'm in the middle of a
graveyard in the wrong place at the
wrong
[Music]
time
[Applause]
that was
fun
man held up good Alex the only downside
to this is it tires your wrist out
really quick cuz you can only hold on
with these three fingers back here
there's really nothing but aside from
that it's tight it's sharp good job you
successfully resurrected a blade from
the grave thank
you how you feeling Trevor nervous
nervous I'm not nervous let's just do
this do it do
it
[Music]
good job thank
you Trevor there's a few issues you do
have some slight Edge damage right here
you can see in the light and your blade
took a bit of a Bend it's noticeably off
to the right big thing though
is this handle uh this pmel and guard um
if I didn't have a glove on it would
tear my hand apart the corners are all
sharp but you survived good job thank
you Jeff how you feeling
scared scared I'm such a nice guy
though that's not a bone guard yeah it's
part of the guard it probably pop right
off as the judges are going over my
blade I pretty much know right then that
some issue with my handle all I can hope
for is my blade is able to be tested
think you could be tested even even L
fairly with the other blades okay so
that's not a b guard all right let's go
tell our
guys Jeff the parameters for this
particular round of competition was that
your knife have a bone guard and a skull
crusher by the end of the round so that
we could test it evenly and fairly with
your competitors you've missed that
parameter and like I said before that's
grounds for immediate dismissal from
this Forge so I'd like to invite you to
shake my hand shake the judge's hands
and then please leave the
forge that thanks I uh completely agree
with the judge's decisions uh I would
have sent myself
[Music]
home